-We do not always
have enough time to cover all
of the recent news,
so here with a recap is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yay! You guys,
things. have. been. crazy.
Okay, so everyone was like,
"COVID is slowing down.
You can hang out
with your friends."
And I was like, "What?!"
Then, Omicron hit
and they were like,
"Stop hanging out
with your friends!"
And I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Omicron got everybody,
especially at late night.
James Corden got it,
and I was like, "What?!"
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy Fallon got it
and I was like, "What?!"
Then, Seth Meyers got it
and I was like, "Wha-a-a-t?!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Seth!
Were you kissing Jimmy Fallon?
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter, applause ]
-[ Changes accent ]
Mind your business.
[ Laughter ]
-I knew it!
Then, while we were all working
from home,
everyone we love died,
and I'm barely exaggerating.
Betty White died
and I was like, "What?!"
Sidney Poitier died and I was
like, "What?!"
Then, Bob Saget died
and I was like,
"What?!
Oh, my gosh!
[ Striking palm ]
All of our favorites are dying!"
Then, Robert Durst was like,
"I died, too,"
and I was like, "No!
[ Laughter ]
Robert Durst,
this is not about you!
Do not try to sneak in there
while we're mourning
beloved Americans.
Shame on you!"
[ Laughter ]
Then, Machine Gun Kelly
and Megan Fox got engaged
[ Cheering ]
and I was like, "What?!
That's fantastic!
I, for one,
cannot wait to see pictures
of their smooth,
angular children.
[ Laughter ]
Then I read about it
and they were like,
"We got engaged
and then we drank
each other's blood,"
and I was like, "What?!
[ Laughter ]
Why do you have
to ruin everything?
You don't need
each other's blood.
What is wrong with you?!
You might [bleep] around
and get a taste for human blood.
Is that what you want?"
[ Laughter ]
Just reckless!
I wouldn't let someone drink
some of my margarita,
let alone some of my blood,
which, by the way,
is mostly margarita.
[ Laughter ]
Then, something
horrible happened.
Jason Momoa and Lisa Monet split
after being together
for 16 years
and I was like, "What?!
I'm devastated!"
But not for them, for me.
[ Laughter ]
Like all Americans,
I desperately wanted them
to make me the third
in their open marriage
[ Laughter ]
and now I am in mourning.
"Did somebody say mourning?"
Not now, Robert Durst!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, let's talk
about Lisa Bonet's
extremely high standards.
She married Lenny Kravitz
and then Jason Momoa.
Who is she going to marry next,
a beam of light?
[ Laughter ]
Lucky beam of light.
Then, New York Mayor Eric Adams
hired his brother
to be in charge of security.
and everyone was like,
"Wha-a-a-t?!"
But I was like, "What?"
My sister Lacey is the head
of my security detail.
She's keeping me secure
right now.
-Hey! You want me
to throw this guy out of here?
[ Laughter ]
-It's my show!
-No, Lacey,
he's my little friend.
-Oh, yay!
[ Claps ]
-[Both, clapping] Yay!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Then,
the Golden Globes happened
and that was like,
"What, where, when,
and, most importantly, what?!"
Why was it a secret and who won?
[ Laughter ]
I looked it up and you're
never going to believe it.
Best Actress?
Amber Mildred Ruffin.
[ Laughter ]
And then Best Supporting Actress
went to
Amber Mildred Ruffin.
Best Late Night segment went to
"Amber Says What,"
which beat "A Closer Look"
by 6,547 votes.
-Hey!
-Don't make me throw you
out of here.
-Alright, okay.
Okay, Lacey.
[ Laughter ]
-Then, speaking of award shows,
okay, so, after three years
of going without a host,
the Oscars are finally going
to get one!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yay!
And, as the winner
of the Golden Globe
for Hostiest Host,
I think I should be
the one to do it.
Shoot, if Christian Siriano
makes me a dress,
I'll do that [bleep] for free!
[ Laughter ]
Hear me, Christian? Call me!
Then, you will never guess
what happened.
They put Maya Angelou
on the quarter!
[ Cheering ]
I saw that and was like,
"What-what?! Yes!"
They put a woman on the quarter.
It better not be worth 20 cents.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, I cannot wait to get
my Maya Angelou quarter.
It really is like she
always said --
[ As Angelou ]
People will forget
what you said.
People will forget what you did.
But people will never forget
you're on a shiny coin
in their pocket.
[ Laughter ]
Then, the FDA deregulated
French dressing
and I was like, "What?
[ Laughter ]
Why were they regulating
French dressing,
in the first place?"
So, it turns out there were
certain ingredients
you had to have to qualify
as French dressing,
but now, anything goes!
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "Whoo! What?!
What are they going to put
in it, something illegal?"
So, if that's true, I demand
[ Striking palm ]
the illegal version.
It is my right to have pure,
uncut French dressing,
and I'll settle
for nothing less!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then, I found out
that a huge asteroid
is going to pass
extremely close to Earth today
and I was like, "What?!"
And I just want to say that,
if this is our last day
of existence,
I'mma be so sad
because I don't want to die
[ Slapping thighs ]
without trying that
uncut French dressing!
[ Laughter ]
I want it!
Then, I watched the new season
of "Euphoria"
[ Cheering and applause ]
and I was like,
"Wha-wha-now!"
I was like,
"What a smart decision I made
to not have children."
[ Laughter ]
Those gross little children.
The only thing those babies
should be putting up their noses
is a COVID test.
[ Laughter ]
Then, everyone has been
doing bits about "Euphoria"
on Twitter, talking about how
those kids dress, like,
"This is how I dress for school"
and then it's them
in normal clothes.
And then they're like,
"This is how I dress
for school at Euphoria High,"
[ Laughter ]
and it's them dressed
to go to the club.
And all those were so funny
that we were going to do
a bit about it,
but then I decided, we're not.
-We're not?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No.
-Well, why didn't you tell me?
-That's it, you're outta here.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been...
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everyone!
Check out "The Amber Ruffin
Show" on Peacock.
New episodes return
after the Olympics.
We'll be --
I just have to do this part!
We'll be right back
with Jeremy Irons.
-I said, go!
-Alright, I'm going!
♪♪